Vamos a dividir 9,815 ÷ 65 o calcular cuántas
veces cabe 65 en 9,815. Los invito a pausar el
video e intentar esto por su cuenta. Permítanme
reescribir esto como 9,815 dividido entre 65.
Lo escribimos de esta forma porque es más fácil
manipular los números, esto es algo así como el
proceso estándar, y como veremos cada vez que
dividimos entre un número que tiene más de un
dígito es algo casi artístico y con suerte podrán
apreciarlo así en el transcurso del video. Así que
en primer lugar podríamos pensar en ¿cuántas veces
cabe 65 en 9? Bueno, no cabe en el 9 en absoluto,
así que podríamos ir un dígito a la derecha.
¿Cuántas veces cabe en 98 sin rebasarlo? Bueno,
65 x 1 es 65, así que eso no es mayor. ¿Y 65 x
2? Bueno, eso sería 130, eso sería mayor que 98,
entonces sólo cabe una vez: multiplicamos 1 x
65 que es igual a 65 y luego podríamos restar
para ver cuánto nos queda: 8 - 5 = 3, 9 - 6
= 3. Ahora podemos bajar el siguiente dígito,
este 1 que tenemos aquí. Aquí es donde la parte
artística va a entrar en juego porque tenemos
que calcular cuántas veces cabe 65 en 331 sin
sobrepasarlo. Y podemos mirar estos números y
tratar de redondearlos un poco, podríamos decir
que el 65 al redondearlo se acerca al 70 y,
veamos, este está cerca de 300, de modo que
podríamos decir que 70 cabe en 300. Tal vez
pensemos en cuántas veces cabe 70 en 300 sin
rebasarlo. No cabe exactamente en 300. Bueno,
podríamos decir cuántas veces cabe el 7 en 30.
Sabemos que 7 cabe 4 veces en 30: 4 x 7 es 28,
entonces intentemos con un 4 aquí porque así esto
será 280, 4 x 70 es 280. Todavía nos quedará un
poco, pero lo que sobra será menor que 70,
serán 20. De modo que decimos que si esto es
aproximadamente 70 y si esto es aproximadamente
300, entonces tal vez va a ser lo mismo,
así que probemos con eso. Veamos si cabe 4 veces:
4 x 5 = 20 y llevamos 2, 4 x 6 es 24 + 2 = 26. Y
ahora veamos cuánto nos queda: entonces, cuando
restamos, nos quedamos con 1 - 0 = 1, tenemos
un 3 aquí y un 6 aquí así que vamos a tener que
reagrupar; tomemos 100 del lugar de las centenas,
este se convierte en 200 y pasamos 10 decenas,
estos 100 al lugar de las decenas, así que ahora
tenemos 13 decenas: 13 - 6 = 7 y luego 2 - 2 =
0. ¿Así que funcionó? Bueno, no, nuestro residuo
después de que dijimos que cabe 4 veces es igual
a 71, el 71 que tenemos aquí es mayor que 65,
no queremos que lo que sobra sea más grande que el
número entre el que estamos dividiendo. Podríamos
haber intentado con un número mayor porque nos
quedó un número muy grande, este 4 era demasiado
pequeño. Probablemente deberíamos haber aproximado
este número a 60 y 60 cabe en 300, si hacemos una
estimación diríamos que esto podría estar más
cerca de 5 veces. Entonces aquí es donde entra
en juego la parte artística. Fue muy razonable
lo que acabamos de hacer, pero simplemente no
resultó ser la forma correcta de pensar en ello.
Podríamos decir "Bueno, el 4 no fue suficiente,
sobró demasiado". Probemos ahora con 5: 5 x 5 es
25, llevamos 2, 5 x 6 es 30 + 2 es 32. Muy bien,
nos acercamos mucho más al 331 sin pasarnos, ahora
podemos restar. Una vez más podríamos reagrupar,
tomar 1 decena del lugar de las decenas, esto se
convierte en 2 decenas y esto se convierte en 11,
11 - 5 es 6, 2 - 2 es 0, 3 - 3 es 0, así que sólo
nos sobran 6, que es obviamente menor que 65.
Entonces esto está bien, y si pusiéramos un 6 aquí
nos pasaríamos de 331, y tampoco habría estado
bien, pero de cualquier modo bajemos el siguiente
dígito, bajemos el 5. Así que ¿cuántas veces cabe
65 en 65? Bueno, cabe una vez: 1 x 65. Ignoremos
esto que es del paso anterior. 1 x 65 = 65,
restamos y no tenemos residuo. Vemos que 65
cabe en 9,815 exactamente 151 veces, 151 veces.